let's start good morning how are you I'm
from California
it's it's later in the day but yes
tomorrow I'm not even sure so we'll see
how it goes I'm wide awake right now the
coffee seems to work so I'm going to be
talking to you about what's new in
asp.net core I feel like at Microsoft we
jump way into the new and shiny stuff
and we only talk about the stuff we
shipped yesterday and we don't even talk
about the stuff we ship two months ago
or three months ago when I talked to
people face to face I realize I think
that's a mistake I feel like we need to
tell a bigger full picture so my plan
here is to talk kind of big picture some
stuff you may not know about into one or
some stuff that you heard about months
ago and then it went by and now you
don't remember because we're throwing to
to stuff at you for my reference who
here is running asp net core two one
like seriously in production awesome
who here is not running any asp net core
at all and is embarrassed to maybe put
their hand off but good brave Thank You
sirs thank you thank you everyone that's
so I feel like this is even for me I
mean like it's kind of my job to keep up
with the newest what we just shipped
last week what might come out next week
it's so easy to forget so I want to tell
it kind of a big full picture so we're
gonna start with some dotnet core
general stuff that applies especially to
asp net core developers we're going to
recap some of the exciting stuff in asp
net core two one from Build time frame
and then we're going to be looking at
asp net cor 2:2
we just shipped a preview for this last
week at dotnet Kampf and so I'm gonna be
talking about that as well and then at
the end I'm gonna take a quick look at
blazer so who here was at the blazer
talk yesterday good a lot of you and I
don't have time to do an in-depth I have
time to do a quick look at it and kind
of you know overview it wets your
appetite if you want to learn more of
that kind of thing and I'm gonna try and
pack all this into an hour so good luck
first of all asp.net core 2-1 there's a
lot of stuff in here that really impacts
asp.net developers so one thing is build
peripheral or we'll just look at all
three of these build performance global
tools and then some some of the nuts and
bolts that make your asp net core
applications faster so first of all
build performance and this is not you
know super exciting things say build
performance but it really does make a
difference this impacts your day-to-day
workflow we notice that developers you
know even file new project takes a
little bit to build but when you start
building a larger application it really
impacts your workflow to the point that
you don't build as often as you should
or you don't run your tests as often as
you should that kind of stuff so what we
looked at with this is for a small asp
net core and this is just looking at two
one it's gotten better even since then
but for a small file new project it went
from six seconds to two seconds for a
larger more real-world application
this is orchard is our web large core
example test project and we went from
over a hundred seconds to ten seconds so
this is this is the kind of thing where
this makes a big difference in your
workflow it changes the way that you're
you know you start losing that muscle
memory of like wait wait a while to
build and you can just build all the
time especially if you're using
something like dotnet watch anyone use
dotnet watch really cool so I love that
workflow
I was actually shipping a website last
week and I had the whole dotnet watch
run going on my on my site and I had
Visual Studio code for a lot of CSS
tweaks and like occasionally touching
the back end but not too much
boom-boom-boom it's really really fast
so this build performance makes a big
difference
okay another neat thing is global tools
so this is something where like a lot of
stuff in the asp net world you know we
sometimes look at other platforms and we
go oh that's cool over there we should
learn what they're doing and do
something like that
so other other platforms have things
like this npm has this great global
tools ecosystem there's other platforms
out there like this right
and so instead of requiring you to
install a new get package into your
application to do something what about
if it's global and I want to use it all
across all my projects
don't make me install that package into
every single project right so that that
tool I just talked about dotnet watch
that's something where instead of having
to put it in each project you install it
once as a global tool so we are shipping
a lot of things as global tools and and
we also make it easy for you to build
your own global tools so it really is
just a console application with a few
little tinkering in your CS proj so so
the idea here let me pop over to this
real quick as an example if I go here
are my global tools that I've got
installed right so I do did not switch
and always thank you you're like on the
ball because I always usually it's like
15 minutes later someone's like hey were
you intending to stop it looks like this
is just what we're gonna see the rest of
the day slide show I don't know if it's
because uh this might be a interesting
thing if I kill PowerPoint well it like
stopped oh I'm in presenter for you I
hate presenter view I actually am gonna
kill PowerPoint get out of here do Save
Changes there it is so here's here's my
global tools right so I did dotnet tool
list G these are my global tools I've
got installed some of these there are
some also that we install by defaults or
things like creating and trusting HTTP
certs that's something that we deliver
to you via global tools and these are
other ones that I got and I can go out
this is information about you know how
global tools work on the docks and this
guy on the asp net team actually has
built this list of
global tools so we're working on making
this more discoverable what we'd like to
do is have a tag and NuGet and say
filter down and just show me global
tools but this is really neat these are
ones like Shane Boyer on the CD a team
what wrote one it's a command-line tool
to search the docs there's all kinds of
other ones the cake team built one for
cake there's you know this cows a1 is an
example just to kind of teach you how to
write a basic a basic one but so this is
something where it's good to know about
in terms of just as you're building ASP
Net Applications you're going to be
using global tools and it's also good to
know about in terms of like you can
build your own all right let's hopefully
I open the right one here will pop right
back into it so that's that's I'm going
to be talking no that's the wrong one
I'm going to be talking about global
tools or excuse me a Docs quite a bit
and I do encourage you to to look at the
docs the docs have gotten better and
better over time
nowwe done it again look at me alright
let's see if it's totally gonna work
yeah all right upload failed that is not
what we want to see I don't know maybe
we'll have some maybe I'll get some
surprises out of this - okay span of T
so span of T is an example of something
the asp net team one of their goals when
they first built asp.net core was to
make it a lot faster they looked at the
benchmarks for just asp.net and the full
framework and we didn't compare very
well we were way at the bottom of the
list there's community I'm sure you've
heard about there's these benchmarks
Tech and power benchmark is when we like
to point to when we first started
checking we were way at the bottom we
were terrible and it was something where
it just wasn't a it wasn't on our list
of things to check when we built asp.net
over time then we said then we started
tracking it and and worked to move up
the
list the kestrel HTTP server which we
built so that it could be cross-platform
and not only run on is run all over the
place
part of the work we did there had all
kinds of unsafe memory management weird
tricks we would allocate blocks of
memory and have pointers going into them
and all these crazy things some of the
problems were you had to be a genius to
work on it and also you as a developer
couldn't take advantage of those
advancements and we couldn't take
advantage of it really anywhere else and
then in kestrel so what we did is
abstract this out and we created some
some primitives that allowed reusing all
across dotnet so this is an example span
of T allows you to point at a block of
bytes and read and you know make changes
in it without allocating additional
memory so that's really it is is to
manipulate chunks of data without having
to copy because as you know that's one
of the main performance recommendations
with dotnet is not to allocate memory
because that kicks in the dreaded
garbage collector and everything stops
well garbage is being collected right so
there's this great blog post I recommend
you look look up its performance
improvements in dotnet core to 1 and
this digs into how and why this actually
works what was cool was once they had
this span of T well developers all
around the world can start using it but
the dotnet core CLR and core FX could
start taking advantage of it as well
so what we found for instance is string
builder well the whole web is strings
you know I mean everything you're
dealing with HTML and CSS and all these
things are strings right so what we
found was by just updating things like
the string builder here's an example of
a string builder that is just appending
a hundred thousand times right and
before it was allocating you know what
three point it was allocating and it was
and it took a while so now by making the
change no change in the code above just
by switching to run on dotnet core two
one it's allocating zero memory and it's
going what
as fast here's one more example
something like a stringbuilder you'll
see two examples up above we're calling
to lower on two different strings the
first one has some upper case and the
second one doesn't so when we needed to
actually lower case so on the on the
first example we went what twice as fast
and then on the second one not only did
we speed up you know here it's a third
as it takes a third as long but it
allocates zero memory so the point of
all this is this stuff bubbles all the
way up through the stack here we're just
looking at things like string allocation
and stringbuilder but the idea is and
one of my tips and one of the things I'm
hoping to sell you on is if you are
running on asp net core get to the
newest versions get to asp net core to
one get to asp net core to two when it
comes out because by making zero changes
even if you fall asleep right now you
don't pay attention to any of the other
features I show off you're still going
to want to take advantage of the
performance improvements um and so you
know we always have to say this I'm sure
you've maybe gotten tired of us pointing
at these performance benchmarks but it
really is something we're proud of so
this is an example of a slide
I hate because I have to keep updating
it all the time way the numbers keep
going up every time we run this this
this is this tech and power of benchmark
is its community run it's not it's not
done by Microsoft there's hundreds of
frameworks on there from esoteric ones
that are all in C++ and you know like
kind of are more academic you'd never
actually write a website in it all the
way to you know PHP and and you know
multiple implementations of Java etc so
this is this is what we're seeing by by
running on this and as I showed you some
of that stuff earlier with dotnet core
the changes in dotnet core and how we
handle memory will those of course have
effect in asp net core to one so this is
an example where you know even just
moving again from asp net core 202 to
one we get we get some pretty big
improvements
what we started with and I think this
makes sense but the team started with is
first focusing on just plain text
response get the fundamentals down so
the the the tech empower plain text has
very simple specification it's basically
like with a request to this URL return
you know a set string and that's it
and so we we got fast at that first then
we started bubbling up to things like
database performance in in the fortunes
so the fortunes is a benchmark that
includes data access and also Jason
Jason response right and so these are
things where we really are starting to
see some of those bigger improvements
you know in the more real world
benchmarks okay we're done with the
dotnet core generic stuff we're moving
on to review of what shipped in asp net
core to one so as a reminder asp net
core to one and i will watch and see if
it's so there it stops so I I'm I asked
my guess is that it just ate my slide
additions from this morning which is
maybe good ok so what was I talking
about
oh okay so if we go to so what is
currently shipping you can go to this do
TN et site if you go to like for
instance download you'll see that the
current thing is dotnet core to one so
what I'm going to be showing you for the
next kind of section of time is the
currently shipping stuff what is then
kind of the hot sizzle new preview stuff
towards the end is in this two to
preview to did we get enough two's in
there to wear a tutu and that's over
here right and so I'll be showing you
that later so let's talk about what we
shipped in asp net core two one
so there's a lot of stuff I like to
think of kind of conceptual things
there's there's a good amount of bugs
and issues and improvements and in each
release that are just kind of like oh
this thing needed doing and we did it
but there are some general kind of focus
areas that you'll see so you know one Oh
was get it out the door what
one is the like everyone does oops you
know let's fix some stuff that we found
after we shipped 102 Oh was when we
updated for things like dotnet standard
and once people really started investing
in it companies and stuff like that and
we and started saying here's some
blockers I would love to move to asp net
core but I can't because of this or that
so dotnet standard was a big example of
that we shipped 32,000 a P eyes that had
been and dotnet full framework but
weren't in asp net core two one which
I'm showing you now I feel like these
are the kind of paper cuts of web
development like we had a good we had
all the building blocks here we had a
fast web framework you know we had the
api's in place to start actually
building and shipping and these are the
things that as a developer are just
extra grunt work stuff you always have
to do on a web application so we really
kind of focused on that for our asp net
core to one I mean even if we didn't
that's the story I'm telling you because
that's how it fits in my mind these are
the kind of these are the kind of main
focus areas four to one and then to -
I'm gonna be showing you later there's a
lot of different things we ship there
but one of the kind of key focus areas
there is api's building web api is right
so this I kind of see as the just making
things easier for you as a developer so
one thing is signal are so it's I don't
know if there's a talk here on signal or
signal are has been around kind of for a
while it was something that was
available in asp net for a while and
that is it's a it's a system that makes
it very easy to write real time web
applications right so if you think of
something like a chat application and
i'm chatting and you're sitting there
waiting and you're seeing that i'm
typing and then once i hit enter it
immediately shows up on your screen
that's something that can be a pain to
write in a web app because you're
depending on all these different
browsers with different levels of
support some you know some may have
support for web sockets i may be doing
wet long polling even you know some all
kinds of different things so signal are
shipped a while ago and
that and it had kind of the support for
a graceful fallback so it said I'm gonna
check your browser you know I'm gonna
see what supported if it doesn't support
this I'm gonna fall back to that I'm
gonna fall back to that it keeps falling
back we didn't have support for it in
asp net core until one a to one people
were asking for it and it took a while
to kind of restructure it and do it
right there were some some pretty good
lessons learned here's some stuff we
wish we'd known when we build asp net or
built signal are the first time so so
some of the things that are neat here is
doesn't rely on jQuery anymore the
previous version did so there's a
javascript and typescript client there's
some other kind of modern things support
for message packet cetera there's there
is also support for simplified scale-out
but one thing we found here when we talk
to customers that are building large
implementations with signal are is that
scaling signal are and having this kind
of multiple many people talking to mini
backends and they're relaying messages
back and forth and all that it's
actually kind of hard to set up so we
also ship to asp net signal our service
or excuse me as your signal our service
so this is a hosted back-end and it
makes it very easy for you to kind of
just toggle over in your application so
you can build a signal our app and then
you can say alright I've got something
that works on my machine now let's
actually make something that works for a
lot of people and you flip flip some
code in your application to point at the
back end so yeah it's this line right
here services add signal are add as your
signal are right so that's pretty cool
there's anyone using that as your signal
are it's pretty neat okay next thing
again we're working through that big
list of all these things I don't expect
you to memorize it I haven't got to
memorized I am trying to I guess my main
point on to one is it does make your
life easier if you're not on to one
think about it for these reasons if you
are onto one and you're not using these
features jump on them it's very easy
I've had applications where I built in
one one or two Oh
I've updated updated updated and I
haven't started turning on these
features so it's good to know about so
one neat thing here is identity UI in
scaffolding so how often have you done
file new project
I don't need identity let's not worry
about that
a month later your boss says hey so how
do we log in to this site or you think
oh I'm gonna need to an admin section or
whatever it is right so then you've got
a problem because the only way to add in
that identity stuff into your
application is file new project and copy
a bunch of stuff in and change the
namespaces and get it all here has done
that before come on yeah it's not fun or
and so you always then end up like just
in case I might need identity let's add
it to every single project and that's a
pain and you're dealing with database
migrations and stuff you may never even
need so what we did here is we made it
so that you can very easily add in
identity later but that's not all we
also made it so that here let's let's
actually pop over I think yeah well
we'll do that in a second we also made
it so it's easy to customize and
override the views without like having
to decide so I always worried about
before there's all these views on disk
but then I'm like well if I change them
and then is something gonna break them
in the future am I really supposed to
plus there's tons of files on disk when
you add identity to a project this is
what it looked like in the past so I've
laser power
I do have laser power so this is what we
actually dumped on your disk in the past
that's a lot of files do I need them do
I need to track them in source control I
can't delete them can I change them I
don't know it's a bunch of junk right
and so what we do now with two one and
later is we just put this little thing
here and this Meuse start actually has
like one line of code and that one line
of code actually says go over to this
new get package because all the files
are in there if you want to change them
you can you can you can say I would like
to make
custom login page only and we make it
very easy to do that so the idea here is
it's something where you can add in
identity later and you can also change
it and override it and everything's
wonderful
so let's do
alright so we're gonna do a new project
we're going to create an HP net we'll go
to one yep let's go web app let's do no
authentication we're being brave
so then after I've been coding the way
coding away and then now I say oh shoot
I actually did want authentication in
there so I can do right click add new
item a new scaffolded item and here I've
got this new thing on the list who here
knew about that who here's actually use
this before all right I'm teaching
somebody something so you go in here and
you say add identity now I love this
actually I think this is really cool
because I can go in I can point it at a
different layout I can say I would only
I want to only include log in and log
out pages right and then I can go
through and I'm gonna have to create a
data contacts class and you know off to
do a little bit of stuff okay to use
your class great and then I say okay
let's do that so let's do log in and log
out okay
so I go through and do that and it's
going to scaffold this out it's kind of
set it up for me and it's only going to
include those views that I told it to
now later if I say oh I didn't really
want to change my log out page I just
delete the file and it falls back to the
one that's in the NuGet package and if I
do want to include a new one I just
right-click on it and say add that one
in so later like so here's here's my
I've got an areas now that has identity
that's all in one nice little place
place and I've got just those those ones
that I told it log in and log out so
later if I want to rescaled an add or
remove Heather's I can so I think that's
cool now part of the way that we did
that I've been telling you like hey we
did this all using a nougat package and
that's neat we also made it easy for you
to take advantage of that - so we talked
to people regularly that build things
like say for instance a store and you
need to be able to build in an admin
system
so I want to ship you my cool store
NuGet package and I want to make it easy
for you to go in and admin add and
remove stuff from the store and you know
change the prices and all that kind of
stuff well in the past that's been
difficult to do it's not easy to ship
views in a nougat package so now this is
all you have to do this
razor class library so this razor class
library is a very very simple it
compiles to a nougat package and you get
a folder full of razor pages so you're
throwing your razor pages ship your new
get package I install your new get
package and it's good to go and it has
that whole thing in there still for I
can override any file by putting one
into my project with the same name and
delete it and it falls back to the
original cool stuff alright let's see
what's going on there okay all right
there's a razor class library is good to
go alright security and privacy so these
days browsers are really pushing you
hard to HTTP HTTPS is is a great feature
because it ensures that you are talking
directly to someone else without
tampering in between right so it allows
you now you still need to make sure that
you're trusting the right person but
this does make it easier for you to
ensure that you're not having people in
between tampering / overhearing whatever
so it's a good developer practice from
the beginning right from file new
project to be developing with HTTPS it's
painful to develop something and then
right as you're about to go live or even
after you've gone live say oh shoot now
I have to turn on HTTPS and now Munchie
or maybe your image links don't work or
your CSS references or whatever right
we've done that it's a pain so what the
team did here is make it easy from right
from file new project projects are set
up with a lot of features to just get
you started with HTTPS there's a few
things there's a global tool that
installs a developer
sir so this is a local testing cert and
it's just built in for you so Visual
Studio that project I just built that
had HTTP already turned on I didn't have
to do anything
so that cert is locally trusted we also
have support in there for HTTP
redirection so we actually support an
HTTP endpoint and an HTTP endpoint and
by default it'll automatically if you go
to the HTTP endpoint no problem we
redirect you to HTTPS so that's cool and
again that's just middleware that's
turned on by default and then there's
also support for our HT th STS and sni
so again just things that are gonna make
it easier for you to develop from the
start with HTTP it's I love the way that
it's been implemented it's I feel like
it's something where it doesn't get in
my way usually in the past if I didn't
use HTTP or HTTPS at the beginning of my
project it was because I was just like
hah
I don't have time for that now and this
is great it's just setup by default so
also with gdpr and just general privacy
you know wanting to do the right thing
for your customers privacy anyways
there's a lot of stuff that's built in
for you and again this helps you with
complying with regulations and also just
trust for your users so their support
for things like cookie consent when the
cookie consent is not just a banner that
says click I accept cookies it actually
has things in there that will not write
cookies to your you know to the browser
unless the user has clicked on accept
and there's also support in there they
it's a pretty rich API there's support
in there for things like this cookie is
required for essential you know it's
essential for site operation and so then
it can still be written there's there's
all kinds of handling with that one
other thing in there is support for
identity data so again there's there's
more to gdpr than just requirement for
clicking on a banner there's also things
like nope that's this one here
dear I think maybe it's in here if not
off to recreate the application there's
also support in there for tracking user
personalization data and being able to -
there's this right to be forgotten and
so the idea here is that I can go in and
I can say not sequel server object
Explorer that I can go in and and say
you know delete me and all my data and
it goes away okay so I this is actually
basically a file new project but I did
add in I called it security and gdpr so
I did every time I showed this off I
realized that I have to create a new
user with log in and then I have to
apply migrations and all that stuff just
to show login and so I have saved you
that minute of watching me try and type
to log in a password and mistyped that
password several times so there's really
nothing on this site other than I've
created a user like that is seriously it
so let's go to me hopefully I'm logged
in cool so this is me now if I click on
me I can see here I've got things like
I've got personal data I can download my
data and I can delete my data so this
again if you're using the asp net
identity system and you're adding
additional things if you're overriding
your application user and adding
additional things on there then those
things as well are tracked and deleted
so if i go in and i download my data to
see what's there it's just a simple JSON
file and so this is me
it's got my good it's got my email it's
got my phone number there we go right so
so that's that and then I can say no I
don't like that and I can delete myself
and that data gets removed so that's
built in it's just there for you and
this is that this is that local H HTTP
cert and the way that's configured here
is in this startup so there's a few
settings for it but as far like there's
my HT th STS and there's a use HTTP
redirection and then there's also their
settings as well for which are my two
endpoints right so I've got a um it's
actually in properties lunch settings
right so I've got my ssl port and stuff
so this makes it really easy to develop
right from the start with things like
security privacy and all that and kind
of starts you off in the right direction
cool all right cool there's that alright
so I'm gonna have to talk faster and
skip maybe a few demos because there's
so much good stuff
MVC functional testing the the idea here
is NBC from the beginning was built so
that you could write unit tests easily
but there's more to test than just you
know when I call my controller does it
return something containing this string
you also want to write tests that are
verifying the functionality of your
application and so so these this was
this was a feature where we built so
that you can actually test that out
makes it a lot easier to run tests
completely in memory so that you are not
just unit testing a function your unit
testing functionality but you don't have
to spin up the entire site to test it
and you know use selenium or whatever to
bang off it I think I do have something
[Music]
let's see if I have one ready if I don't
I will just move right on because demos
about unit tests are super
okay I mean I'm just saying nope hey
let's go over here
alright just trust me it's super cool
you'll love it it's the best thing ever
unit testing all right cool
API controller and action result of T so
so some of the main stuff here is
there's a lot of stuff in building an
API that to do it right
requires following a bunch of rules
returning the right things telling
endpoints what type what types you're
returning that kind of stuff so it is
important to get that right to build you
know build something that's useful to
your clients however it can be pretty
repetitive so this is something that
started in 2/1 and continued more into
two so with two one there's support for
this API controller and you can drop it
right on the entire controller and it
does smart things like attribute routes
only and stuff like that and figures out
you know like for instance infer from
body for complex types so stuff that you
should have been putting in all your API
controller methods all those attributes
this is going to kind of figure that out
for you also there's support for action
result of T so this is a generic action
result so what's neat I do think I have
one of these already going yep okay
see I have two different things that
open I have some of these in the preview
and some not okay this is totally gonna
work
no okay no worries so if I if I create a
if I created an API pointed at a type
and scaffold it actually I may have it
already open in this one here I've got
an API I've got it scaffolded and it's a
it's going to have a type for my get
method
nope it doesn't this one doesn't okay
let's do it so so we'll create an API
will point it at a simple model and then
we'll scaffold it out
so what this allows you to do is your
API wilt will tell endpoints and if
you're doing things like generating
swagger and stuff like that they can say
oh okay this doesn't just return some
weird anonymous type it actually returns
say in this case we'll do a person right
so do a person and our person is going
to have an ID and a name
cool so now when we scaffold this out
let's scaffold out and out of controller
cool so we'll do that so this is an
example of something where you don't
have to do anything different you just
you know by the act of scaffolding it
out we now are doing this telling
telling the end result what kind of type
we've got and this is built using the
kind of stuff under the hood that does
action result of T right so here we go
so this is returning an ienumerable of
person and this this is you know not
just a change in the scaffolding but the
actual API controller infrastructure to
be able to handle that so cool and I was
yeah ok HTTP client factory this is
really cool so the idea here is if
you've got code in your web application
that's calling over to another API
getting data from someone else as an
example on the dotnet comping where we
have a bunch of local events going on
all around the world we have all these
local events and we have this whole long
convoluted process to get them in there
and now we actually have a thing where
people enter these in a SurveyMonkey
thing and then we go in process them
make sure they're on our list and then
we map them so just in this page I'm
calling the Survey Monkey API and I'm
calling Bing to geo locate them right so
in order to do things right with an API
you end up writing a lot of repetitive
code or excuse me an HTTP client you're
having to say you know here's the
endpoint for all these calls and if
something goes wrong here's how to
handle it for github you have to include
some special headers or they won't
listen to you so you know and then
there's all kinds of like smarter things
about fallback and that kind of stuff so
we actually made it so you can
centralized things in one place
so as an example who here was at our
workshop earlier this week anybody know
only Glen so in this we had a multi-tier
application where we had a client
multiple people were calling into these
controllers and so we actually built an
API client so we have an AI API client
which we say here's the different things
that can support and then we have these
implementations right so these are all
the different kind of specific methods
go get a list of sessions and attendees
and stuff what's cool with this now is I
can go into my startup and I can
register it in one place so I can say
add HTTP client it's just plugged into
the dependency injection so instead
instead of this I could say I get hub
client and github client you know
implementation whatever it is so here in
one place I set my base address this is
great because now I don't have to track
that configuration setting all around my
application I do it in one place and
then in any of my pages that are calling
into it I just inject that API client so
I can go here here I've injected that
API client and then I can just make
calls to it so there's a lot more to it
but but that's kind of an example of how
you can standardize and put it all in
one place all right we updated our HP
nut core spa templates I'm gonna move
right on to the - to preview so - to
preview we just announced it last week
preview - was just announced at at
dotnet Kampf last week so I showed you
before if you go to do t dot any t
there's a thing up at the top there's a
little banner that says install it in
order to install it you'll need the
latest Visual Studio preview which you
can go to visual studio comm slash
preview all this stuff runs side by
sides I've got them on my laptop I've
got you know the current visual studio
and the visual studio preview I've got
multiple SDKs on there they're all are
built to run side by side so not scary
totally do it it's cool okay
wow that was a transition so let's
look at what's in here first of all we
updated our template some more so you
know the web mode is fast we have to
keep up so we have bootstrap 4 and
angular 6 so if I go in here if I do
let's close this guy let's do this is my
so here I was starting to do this in the
wrong visual studio let's go into this
one so this is Visual Studio preview you
can see that little purple preview if I
go in here and create a new web
application and so there's kind of two
big things that I see about this feature
one is that we're it's running on all
the latest libraries 2 has said it's
also simplified quite a bit so what we
notice is our file new project templates
tend to grow over time ours had the kind
of jumbotron with the stuff moving
around and the bulleted list that nobody
ever reads and so instead of making you
go in and delete a bunch of stuff these
are actually built pretty lightweight so
here's what the index page looks like
now it's just like welcome right pretty
low-key so that's about as minimal as
you can get so you'll see in here you
know we've got support for bootstrap for
we've got and then if you do the new
angular ones you get that as well so
this is this is very lightweight we got
into this I think it's on four one three
yep there it is so that's cool all right
some other stuff we'll look at ap is
let's let's spend a little time looking
at AP eyes so AP eyes are all over the
place
and so as I mentioned before this is a
feature or a focus area for to to is
making building good API is easier
Glenn showed you some of the demos
yesterday if he went to his session I'm
gonna look at a few more but some of the
ideas here as far as making
easier so creating make it easier to do
API scaffolding that that works well and
points you in the right direction
testing and debugging so we've got an
HTTP repple so instead of always having
to go out and and you know get postman
or fiddler or whatever if you just want
to inspect either your API or any API on
the web this makes it easier to do as
far as documenting there's a there's an
analyzer that makes it easier to that
makes it easier to identify things you
could attribute better in your
application but even better we have
conventions that lay on top of that so
by adding these conventions on it'll
automatically return useful things to
your end clients without you having you
having to go in and make those changes
yeah so those are and then we'll also
show health checks in HTTP two in a
second here so let's talk about we have
API improvements so I don't yeah that's
it all right so let's look at a couple
things we are going to go into I'm going
to create a new one
all right so if I go in here we'll
create a new API so I'm in I've set HP
net core to to up there create an API we
will get in a model
I was gonna do a thing with venomous
animals but there's really a lot to the
problem space you have to really think
that through
I would give at age
okay cool that's me okay
so cool so now we're going to generate a
we're going to create a new controller
cool we'll do API I guess we'll use on a
framework that made me make me skip over
some of this because I'm gonna have to
do migrations and stuff what I want to
show you is really just two things I
want to show first of all putting that
analyzer on here so there's an analyzer
and I have one here that's completed
which is this line here so you there's a
line that you add into your CS proj to
turn on this analyzer
so now if before doing this if I just do
a build so I'll like yeah you built the
world's best API so now let's go in
let's edit our CS proj and we're gonna
add in it's an analyzer and now we'll
build it and it should tell me
it's like oh okay so here's some things
that I could do better this is because
of that analyzer so for instance it's
saying here I should return a 201 right
so for a post method I should be
returning a 201 and there's things in
here working it can go in it can correct
i'm or i can suppress some if needed
right so here I can go control dot and
produces type and now I'm good there
right and so for kind of all of these
it's not found it really should be
returning instead this
so this analyzer will go in and it'll
look at all my my returns and stuff and
say wow you know you're you're not
writing good API you're a bad person and
you really need all these attributes
right but what's even better is I could
instead use conventions to handle this
so here's an example of so this one by
dropping this line in here so I'm
turning on these conventions and now I
still have pretty not super attributed
you know looking thing I don't have to
put all those on but and this has that
same analyzer put on but it's going to
be happy with me and it's not going to
tell me I'm a bad person because I've by
convention got all those attributes
applied so cool so one other thing I
want to show you here is this repple so
this is that HTTP ripple so this is a
global tool I spelled it wrong huh thank
you cool so this is a global tool I
mentioned before about global tools and
you can look this one up this is out on
nougat right there so it's dotnet tool
installed - - global dotnet HTTP repple
so that's all that's required there so
then I can do things like set base HTTP
so I could do like API github calm
right so now it's pointing at github and
now I can just do it get and this is
gonna go and tell me all the different
things and I can go through and explore
them or I could go in and I could point
at my own API and do the same thing
right and so I can explore my API and
test it from command line so this really
helps me with my workflow I'm building
an API on my machine and then I'm able
to kind of inspect it and say well you
know what is that returning so there's
there's a couple other things that we're
adding into the the project templates to
make it easier for you to interoperate
and so some of these are by creating
swagger documentation so swagger
documentation basically allows someone
else to pin your API request the swagger
json doc and and that will say here's
all the endpoints here's what you know
here's what you can expect from this and
you know here's here's what everything
returns etc and so so there are two two
NuGet packages that enable this make
this easy to do so there's a swashbuckle
and there is I'm pointing at the wrong
one okay so a swashbuckle makes it easy
you add the swashbuckle package to your
project and then it makes it easy to
inspect the API so this is an HTML based
thing I can say give me a list of you
know in this case pets that are on there
I could actually go in and create one so
I can you know click on this and do try
it out and create one and and fill in
the blanks and add it so this this
really does make it nice I wonder if I
can be Sephirah self-referential and I
am my own pet person I'm gonna break it
our night
100 okay
cool I think I might have created myself
twice which is fun cloning cool so yeah
I got some air probably because I
created myself twice but so swashbuckle
assists a package that makes it easy to
add in then there's also support for
ends wag and end swag is a cool package
it actually builds a client code so this
makes it easy for you to build out a
client so we've actually got that
enabled in this project and we've got
that using if we look at CS proj here so
there's a build task in here using this
project no we don't have that installed
so that's this project called n swag
that might be in this if not you'll just
have to trust me but it's a cool it's a
cool system for allowing like once we've
got it in one place and I don't have an
install I don't have time for it anyhow
but so the idea here is to make it
easier to both produce documentation
about my application and then using this
n swag project to go in and say based on
that documentation build me a client so
build me either c-sharp code or build me
a typescript client or that kind of
thing so this is definitely this is
something that's that's being developed
for asp net core to to is kind of a main
focus area alright two other things to
squeeze into six minutes here http/2 so
this is something that's being built in
by default HTTP 2 requires HTTPS now
that we have HTTP kind of already turned
on and set up for you this is just
automatically going to run for you so
this is something where you don't have
to make a change it just automatically
will take advantage of that and then in
process hosting so long ago the way that
ASP newer you know the way traditional
asp net applications worked on the full
framework with is is as a you know as a
module built in is like you basically
your application ran inside of the
process of IAS
then later when we built out Kestrel and
it had to run on any machine could be an
engine ax could be a docker whatever so
the hosting model is it's a separate
separate exe it's a separate you know
dotnet orchestral host and then you
would call into it so I is actually had
a very lightweight asp net core module
that called in and so there's separate
processes so that causes some some delay
because there's there's more
communication etc plus maybe a bigger
problem is if something went wrong was
difficult to troubleshoot hard to find
out what was going on and so now there's
actually support for asp net core module
running inside the is worker process and
so here's an example of you know the
performance benefit just of doing that
so you'll see I believe I have that in
here if we look at an ICS proj this is
what's we required to turn that on it's
just this asp net core hosting model so
this is if you do file new project
that's going to be set up for you if you
have an existing project that you
migrate this is something you'll want to
look at toggling if you're running
inside of is so cool all right I want to
take a very quick look at oh well so
there's also health checks health checks
do i have already open health checks are
super easy to turn on so the idea here
with health checks it's already included
in the meta package so you just there's
they use health checks to tell it what
the endpoint is and then you can say add
health checks for a very basic or you
can do some things like here's an
example where I've got adding a check
for a database connection so here I've
got a something to check if I'm able to
connect to my database what's nice with
this is I can say my application is only
healthy if I can get to the database and
I configure it so that if for instance
one instance of my application is not
reachable here's an example where as
your real
and fails over I I'm going to take the
very quickest look at blazer and then
we're gonna move on to your next session
so so so here's here's kind of the big
picture we just ship preview to and rtw
by end of the year
cool so the idea with blazer is
basically I'll just give you the
elevator pitch for it if you want to
build an application with if you are
mostly a.net developer and you're you
know you are you're comfortable with
building with razor and c-sharp you
would like to have you know write
front-end app like a front-end
application you would write like to
write something that runs in the browser
that is mostly front-end client and you
don't want to spend a bunch of time it's
not your core skill set to build out you
know an angular build chain or that kind
of stuff so if you go to blazer net you
can learn about this the idea is here is
that you are writing an application
where your front-end code is written in
C sharp and net so I have two quick
examples of that one is if I go to file
new nope okay so here because I've
installed the blazer tools and I'm in
their own project
so I'm going to show you a quick look at
file new with blazer and then I'll show
you an example of one that I built
recently so here you install the the
stuff for blazer by going to blazer net
and it points you at a v6 package so
here I've got that installed and so I'm
going to create a new blazer application
and the thing you'll see here is that it
looks if you just glanced at it you'd
say oh yeah there's just Razor pages and
c-sharp it's very very kind of simple so
here's an example of a page here I'm
doing things like I've got a counter and
when I click on a button it increments
the number excuse me that's this one
here right so I just have button click
code and it updates but the cool thing
is there's there's a few cool things
here one is this is all running in the
browser using web standard technologies
it is it's compiled c-sharp code so I'm
testing I'm getting any kind of c-sharp
you know build and and type checking and
all that I'm getting native compiled
speed performance I'm able to use nougat
packages and I'm able to take advantage
of shared libraries so if I've got a
class library on the server you know
maybe that's my you know my person class
or whatever it is I can also use that
down on the client so here's an example
we built out this this conference
planner application which is like a
website planning application and I built
out a front-end for it using blazer the
other day and the idea here is I've got
there's a very simple example I showed
you that API client before here's an
example that's calling into that API
client so I'm just calling get Jason
async this is standard c-sharp code with
intellisense and debugging and all that
and and so it's able to you know take
advantage of all that kind of c-sharp
development knowledge that i've got and
you know i don't have to try and move
into a different problem space so of
course we still we have support for
those templates for for angular etc
templates we still you know continued
eleven support
all those things but we do think this is
kind of an interesting idea if you are
if you're a c-sharp developer and you
want to build front-end stuff so if you
are interested you need to let us know
this is something where Microsoft is
still figuring out if it's a committed
product or not so if you can go to
blazer net U and install this and then
at the end of it once you run file new
project there's a little thing that says
a survey let us know and then we can say
okay bosses let us ship this so here's
an example where I've gone in and I've
built this conference application it's
hitting this back-end API and what's
neat is that this is all done
client-side now so I can filter I can do
all this stuff I can do c-sharp linked
queries etc and that's all handled on
the client okay
we packed a ton of stuff in my main goal
again was to kind of survey an overview
what's what's new and exciting in asp
net core if you are interested you can
go to again for blazer go-to blazer net
otherwise go to do tian ET and and also
to the asp net weblog and there's
there's they've been doing really good
feature overview posts lately on all
this stuff so i'll be here through the
end of the day tomorrow happy to take
your questions now or later through the
week thanks a bunch
[Applause]